[Musique]
en quelques mots emmanuel macron vient
de mettre un coup d'arrêt à la campagne
de vaccination à peine commencée dans
les pharmacies suite à la suspension du
vaccin astrazeneca nous ne pourrons pas
vous vacciner demain 14h30 comme prévu
des annulations en cascade chez ceux
formation reste du coup et 5,5 doses que
j'aurais pu utiliser mais que du coup je
n'utiliserai pas fait ce que le vaccin
est tué valable pendant 48 heures après
ouverture ce que je vois surtout c'est
que ça affaiblit notre stratégie
vaccinale parce que la france a commandé
beaucoup de vaccins astrazeneca
j'espère que la décision qui sera prise
sur la base d'une étude scientifique ce
sera qu'on puisse redémarrer ma méthode
est très très maladroite et en réalité
les effets secondaires
ça va être une augmentation du doute
c'est un peu comme la diffamation c'est
à dire que toute façon même si on
innocente et le vaccin astrazeneca il en
restera toujours quelque chose et on va
ramer on va ramener donc quelle que soit
la situation va ramer pour ce vaccin là
dans ce communiqué le groupe
pharmaceutique se défend aujourd'hui
ces chiffres sont bien inférieurs à ceux
que l'on s'attendrait à observer
naturellement dans une population
générale de cette taille et sont
similaires à ceux des autres vaccins les
événements observés l'ont tous été dans
les dix jours qui ont suivi la
vaccination
donc on peut penser déjà que pour ceux
qui ont un délai supérieur en tout état
de cause ils ne doivent pas s'inquiéter
pour pour ceux qui ont été vaccinés très
récemment
je dirais simplement les traces entier
s'il se passe quelque chose d'anormal de
consulter leur médecin c'est du bon sens
il ya très peu de cas de thrombose qui
sont advenus au moment où les personnes
qui les ont eus ont été vaccinées c'est
très peu mais est ce constat des
étudiants c'est un problème ou pas c'est
ce que doit nous dire
lagence du médicament va nous attendons
je l'espère pour jeudi après-midi une
forme de verdict de la part de la
communauté scientifique européenne nous
permettant je le souhaite encore une
fois ardemment de pouvoir reprendre la
campagne on a un président de la
république
qui change d'avis comme de chemise parce
que l'allemagne a changé d'avis si
l'europe hésite les britanniques eux ont
toute confiance en leurs vaccins malgré
les cas de thrombose le premier ministre
a décidé de continuer la campagne de
vaccination il n'existe absolument
aucune raison de suspendre le programme
de vaccination
le vaccin est parfaitement sur les
entiers vax aujourd'hui se régaler ses
ils n'ont même pas besoin de parler
tout se fait sans eux non il ya un
problème de ce fameux principe de
précaution qui fait qu'on a arrêté parce
qu'il ya un je vous rappelle quand même
qu'il ya un cas un mort sur un million
de vaccinés et si une partie des cas et
est en réalité passé sous les radars on
a détecté un nouveau variant un bar et
en breton des patients sont bien
contaminé mais les tests ont beaucoup de
mal à le détecter
c'est un nouveau variant qui fait
l'objet de toutes les attentions des
autorités de santé
cette mutation est apparu dans l'hôpital
de lannion dans les côtes d'armor
comme ce variant en effet est plus
difficilement détectables nous avons du
mal à estimer le dénominateur et donc
par rapport à ça en fonction de la
circulation du virus et de ce qu'on peut
identifier
il est délicat d'apprécier sa
transmissibilité
en attendant tous les prélèvements
positifs effectués ces derniers jours en
bretagne et dans d'autres régions vont
être séquencé pour évaluer la
circulation du barca des mesures sont
également prises dans les côtes d'armor
pour freiner la transmission du virus
par du masque obligatoire alcool
interdit sur la voie publique tout comme
les brocantes et les vide greniers les
césar c'est une vitrine pour vendre
notre cinéma à l'international est ce
que vous voyez l'image que ça a donné
donc c'est navrant de voir des artistes
piétiner leur outil de travail
je n'ai pas envie de répondre à madame
bachelot ni aux chiens de garde de
du gouvernement parce que je ne les
écoute pas par principe je n'écoute pas
j'imagine que ça devait pas être très
gentil
ce qui est dommage c'est que le
répugnant de le dire puisque elle était
dans la salle au début semble-t-il elle
s'est barrée chiffres émanent candidat à
la prochaine élection présidentielle de
2000 km2